hello everybody install the locksmith in
this video we'll be doing all keys lost
for 2016 Acura TLX using the autel K100
and I'll tell Universal ikey
first we'll generate the key with the I
key in the coil
go to Universal key
thank you
TLX
let's go back
2016.
generate Universal key
foreign
how to program the key will go to Imo
push to start
yes
control unit
keyless system Honda
two
application is not turned on we say no
to stop on
okay
[Music]
he's lost
ignition off
[Music]
okay no
thank you
[Music]
ignition is on okay
one key
okay
[Music]
ignition off
one two
is on
yes the lights are all off
yes
ignition off
finish on one
two
registration complete ignition off
just to keep this access remote
so yeah unlock
turn the ignition switch on
one two
[Music]
registration is complete let's try and
start the vehicle
and she's a runner
all keys lost 2016 Acura TLX
with the autel km100 thank you for
watching have a great day